New York City's migrant crisis is only
getting worse the so-called Sanctuary
cities migrant shelters are officially
out of room and we're seeing migrants
spill into the streets of Midtown
Manhattan with no other place to go
hundreds have set up camp outside the
city's iconic Roosevelt Hotel and scenes
like this are becoming far too common
across the Big Apple the situation is so
dire that the city is now reportedly
considering converting soccer fields
used by children on Randall's Island to
additional shelters and now mayor Eric
Adams is calling for more help and
sending this warning to resident New
Yorkers
eventually this was going to come to a
neighborhood near you and it is we need
to control the Border
we need to call a state of emergency and
we need to properly fund this National
crisis we need help we need we need help
and it's it's not going to get any
better from from this moment on is
downhill
there is no more room and Bill Maher is
now calling out the leaders of the
democrat-run cities for failing to
address the issue
it's again the same Principle as I was
saying before about like the reverse of
what liberalism really is liberalism is
for the sake of humanity and compassion
can we get these people off the streets
and woke is how dare you ask them to
move this is their home they have rights
no it's not we there's got to be there's
easily a better solution to this but
instead they put them in hotels
that's your answer hotels could
everybody just stop the posturing don't
pretend that you love migrants so much
and then when we send them to you you
don't like them
you know you're foolish and we can see
that
yeah you like them when it wasn't your
problem because you're not a border
state
[Laughter]
and then when they show up in Chicago
and New York you're like what the
what's going on with these people
about this because it really is serious
but when I heard about this story I went
down and I was interviewing some of the
little kids in the soccer fields and
they're tired of being kicked around
all right so we plan that well but
seriously you guys the little kids I
understand through my research 3 000
hours of sports events will be canceled
because as Bill Maher said these people
you can't say you know don't come here
we want to move them to the soccer
fields so all these little ones that are
out trying to deal with obesity trying
to deal with the depression now they're
all out of their soccer games the
parents the adult teams that we all need
so much all of this is kicked to the
curb forgive me but no pun intended but
seriously now all of the migrants 93 000
I think today are uh going to be in
these soccer fields yeah doctor to her
point three thousand hours are projected
to be canceled of of activities of
public and private school kids adults
included and you know these these
residents are also paying for this with
their tax dollars so they're being taxed
and they're paying for it and then
they're losing what they've already paid
for with their tax dollars to create
those other relational programs Emily
it's a threat to the public health of
people who are citizens here and let me
give you the facts on this it's it's not
just about the sanctity of our borders
which is huge it's also a public health
emergency here I actually have been
treating some of the migrants outside my
office in the heat on the street trying
to save them and having to send them to
the hospital because the one thing
that's not being talked about is heat
exposure and infectious diseases that
are coming across and mayor Adams was
like well we're a sanctuary City he said
that a year ago let me tell you one more
thing we have about 70 to 80 000
homeless in New York already and they
have shelters and almost every one of
them has a bed at night that's not
perfect because the shelter system has a
huge problem but it's a big improvement
from when I was in my training at
Bellevue before the shelters were there
Improvement there's no room in the
shelters whatsoever for additional
people that are here illegally you know
Martha the mayor says they're coming for
to a neighborhood near you talking to
New Yorkers but I argue that sentence
can be applied to all Americans because
every state is a border state well I I
live in a New York border state in New
Jersey and I can tell you that the
homeless population has increased there
as well because people are pushing out
of the Cities that's already happening
and you know Eric Adams may be stumbling
on a solution here because do not tick
off soccer moms they are very determined
to get their kids to soccer to get them
to football practice whatever so he's
messing with a group that is super fired
up and will not stand I mean I'm telling
you people are way more serious about
sports and academics in the current
environment the United States so that I
think will will be a trigger I think
Bill Maher is 100 right so much
hypocrisy it is dripping with hypocrisy
when you look at the way the situation
has been oath and one thing that we
didn't hear there Sharon Osborne said
she's moving back to London because she
said they don't allow people to sleep in
the street there it's against the law
when I was a kid they used to have you
know they literally the police would
come out with like you know sweeps
brooms I'm sorry sir you can't sleep
here you got to find somewhere else to
go they would they would clear all the
streets around Port Authority and they
had benches that had little in them so
that it wasn't comfortable to sleep on
them obviously you're so Humane and
you're helping these individuals and I
think God bless you for that absolutely
we have to find Humane Solutions but
people cannot sleep all over the streets
it's just untenable it's not going to
work and to Martha's point you know it
started to remember with in the public
schools giving up their gymnasiums we
talked to at length about the parents I
came out and said not in my school not
my kid and then now it's it's their
Recreation too great what a great idea
put single adult males in gymnasiums buy
children okay bad idea guys that's just
common sense but the bottom line here is
words are cheap actions are real words
like we are a sanctuary City but then
the illegal immigrants come and you fail
to provide Sanctuary they get to sleep
on the street uh we care about illegal
immigrant children is another thing we
hear from the bleeding heart liberals
well no you don't because when vice
president Kamala Harris our borders are
went to the Border guess where she
didn't go emergency intake facilities
where kids were trying to commit suicide
or they had to take away n95 respirators
because they were slitting their wrists
where they had suicide watchless where
they were eating chicken with bloody
feathers so I am tired of hearing about
Sanctuary City we care for the kids you
don't care for the kids your leaders
don't at least I believe some in the
party do your leaders they don't they
just point in fingers they blame game
all day all night invited way to go
premature Victory lap you said illegal
immigration coming down numbers in July
130 000 up from the previous month 95
000 fix the problem yeah well he also
said we cured cancer so apparently
everybody
all right guys hey everyone I'm Emily
compagno catch me and my co-host Harris
Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights